quel avenir pour la maison de la culture
de bourges d'un côté le projet de la
mairie sur les pentes ombragé de la
place séraucourt de l'autre le contre
projet est porté par un collectif
citoyen et cette folle idée pourquoi ne
pas reconstruire un bâtiment tout neuf
derrière la célèbre façade en briques
c'est ce que pense christian gimonnet
cet architecte travaille depuis deux ans
sur les plans du site historique
j'ai pu découvrir que par le fait qu'on
avait démoli des murs ont ré ouvre et on
n'était plus dans l'ue la contrainte des
murs qui existait auparavant et que ça
permettait de tout à la fois d'offrir
les dispositifs scéniques requis dans
cette exposition le collectif décortique
le projet de la mairie baptisé mcb 2 les
surcoûts liés aux travaux de voirie et
de réseaux ont été estimées à 10
millions d'euros supplémentaires alors
que le maire avait annoncé 36 millions
d'euros de budget global les ans et
occupe cible font eux le pari d'une
maison de la culture
beaucoup moins cher nous proposons une
faisabilité d'un projet contemporain 9
derrière les mètres carrés existants de
la maison de la culture à 25 millions
entre 25 et 40 6 nous avons 19 millions
de différence donc les contribuables
donc quand même leur mot à dire pour un
même projet de maison de la culture le
même programme qui coûterait près de 20
millions de moi sur le site historique
depuis un an
riverain jeunes retraités ou simples
sympathisants manifeste fond des recours
juridiques empêchent l'abattage des
arbres
aujourd'hui c'est berruyer sont un peu
nostalgiques faut vraiment le défendre
parce que on conserve une façade est
extraordinaire un lieu qu'ont connu
effectivement les berruyers comme moi
qui sont un petit peu âgé entre
guillemets et on n'y a vécu des choses
qu'on aimerait revivre une maison
historique
inauguré par malraux et de gaulle une
maison ouverte à tous les publics y à
toutes les formes d'art un lieu en
avance sur son temps alors
qu'aujourd'hui les retards s'accumulent
la rénovation avait été prévu en 2005
les déclarations
des élus laissent la crainte que 20
pendant quelques années il ne se passe
rien et nous nous sommes vraiment des
défenseurs de l'idée d'une maison de la
culture finalement un statu quo
préjudiciable aux spectateurs berruyer
depuis dix ans il n'y a plus de maison
la culture à bourges